hi I'm soaking wet hi I'm Garrett and
I'm Nikki
we're fascinate about how other people
live so we're gonna try to find some
really interesting living situation and
live there see what it's like to have a
totally different lifestyle and see
which one's bring us closer together and
push us further apart this week though
we're gonna be drifting a little bit
closer yeah you didn't pedal I wasn't
paddling very hard Gary
Nikki nice to meet you my name is Lisa
and I have lived on coop davila for
almost nine years and it's the best move
I've ever made my life
well thank you to Villa there's one of
the cats cats Wally
okay he's the friendly one so this
houseboat has two cats and I'm allergic
to cats cats on a boat that's pretty
funny I've never been on a houseboat I
think I've seen houseboats before it's a
house on water or is it boat that you
can live on well no I guess I was on a
cruise ship is that a houseboat all
these people that live on boats here
this is considered the lobby everybody
stops by here so if you're sitting out
here enjoying yourselves
somebody else may stop by they all stop
by so my checklist for living in the
houseboat is can I survive the cats is
there a kitchen that's big enough that I
feel like I could live here and is there
a garret sized shower this is the living
room you can see there's lots of room in
here yeah this is awesome and a
full-size kitchen so my checklist for
living in this houseboat is that one
Garrett and I have enough space to share
two that I have some of those private
spaces where I can either close a door
or be in a different room three I like
living in quiet places I don't like
living near busy roads or highways and I
don't know if it's gonna be like on a
marina a houseboat isn't really like
living on a boat it has three bedrooms
two bathrooms it has a washer/dryer I've
got a full-size kitchen with full-size
refrigerator and electric stove pretty
much everything you could need you go
here and go down to the right Oh sir
downstairs yeah this is the bedroom that
people usually stay in down there oh wow
oh my goodness yeah
so it's pretty comfy that's actually it
looks really cool and there oh wow oh
look at that you're like right at eye
level at the water cool yeah this is
this is like a little hideaway Wow both
the challenges are probably storage the
biggest surprise is how little I could
make do with it I moved from a 5,000
square-foot house and put everything
into a u-haul with my two cats and drove
out here
so this is where I love to sit in the
evening and yeah sunsets right over
there beautiful
well dumb question yeah does it rock
this is you know I mean this is so wide
and the bottom is flat it doesn't rock
much at all this is awesome Lisa we're
not just saying that cuz the cameras
rolling this is like yeah this is I knew
you guys Nikki and I are friends now
like we're definitely work friends in
the meantime Nikki got married which I'm
very happy for her
he did not come to the wedding even
though he was all still knows about it
may become her wedding he did get us a
gift which was very nice he didn't have
to do that there you go I'm very excited
about this homebodies sweet home buddy
so Gary and I have lived together on two
occasions now this will be our third
time living together till I keep
building this relationship I think we
need to figure out how to move past work
friends into like friends friends
alright I'm gonna go in here means I go
down below I hope there are no kitty
cats are you allergic to cats
yeah my goal for the houseboat is to see
if we can make plans to hang out outside
of work because I think that'll be the
actual difference between work friends
and real friends this is so cozy
Nikki flat do you need any baskets I
have extras you know baskets baskets
get off of my bed now I fit perfect look
it
I also fit perfect look at you you're
actually adorable I'm an introvert
Garrett is not my goal is to find some a
lot of time that's not to be anti-social
that's not because I don't like Garrett
for me to be a sane and caring human
being I need some time alone well the
space you actually drink alcohol I've
tasted before I just I'm not gonna drink
but doesn't it taste better on a boat
sure
today was day one in a houseboat I
expected the houseboat to be so much
smaller than it is totally feels like
we're living in like a normal apartment
doors on the water we're a lot closer to
the neighbors than I thought hello the
sound travels so much freer Darren I
have our own rooms which i think is
really gonna help this experience like I
have my own space and I can close the
door Lisa was telling us about all these
different kinds of activities they we're
gonna go sailing tomorrow that's gonna
be unbelievable I feel like for the
first time Garrett and I don't have to
be thinking so hard about where we're
living and I think that will allow for
our relationship to grow in a way that
hasn't been able to in the past I knows
it's getting congested because of these
cats
can i thinkI you look very cozy okay
lights out young lady good morning it's
actually a really beautiful morning
they're basically two times when being
six-foot-seven sucks one is on airplanes
and two is anytime you have to shower
the boat actually has two showers but
they're used for storage so we have to
go use the showers in the marina
[Music]
a bunch lot of people walking the dogs
right there hey Nikki you want coffee
[Music]
[Music]
it's brewing good morning happy Friday
[Music]
saving Nikki it's a natural part of boys
body yeah then you don't have to like
worry about it like flying everywhere is
really gross why is it that it's not
that gross a lot of people with dogs
walking by and looking at me like I'm
kind of a weirdo but that's boat living
so Lisa's neighbours usually join her
for breakfast in her lobby area so a few
of them are joining us for coffee this
morning and then her friend chuck is
gonna take us out sailing we're doing
Garrett making you eggs before your sail
[Music]
you just buy this bar to them and turn
this over to you okay
history is one of the things I can teach
it fastest
sailing was so amazing and Chuck let us
steer for a little while
blown away with how good Nikki was at
sailing like she was doing these
complicated steering maneuvers while he
was tacking the sails back and forth it
was really amazing to behold and we did
for like three hours
[Music]
after sailing Garrett and I went
kayaking for a little while and after
that whole day on the water
I was pretty ready to find some alone
time thing about living in a houseboat
is it everything's wet the shorts are
wet the course I'm wearing now or wet
this shirt is wet
this shirt is wet I found the perfect
spot here on this houseboat the top deck
hammock chair great view Nikki I noticed
went upstairs to read alone Gary came up
to like join me and it was one of those
things where like when you're new
friends and there's nothing to talk
about
silence can be kind of awkward it was
totally fine I didn't feel awkward at
all I didn't feel like I needed to fill
that space being near each other but not
really interacting just sort of knowing
the other person was there and that if
either of us need anything like we were
there for each other so I think that was
like a really interesting step in our
relationship Nikki and I are about to
good dinner we had a pretty incredible
day I think if I said like hey would you
want to hang out I said work she'd say
yes so at dinner tonight I think I'm
gonna try to achieve my goal so we just
finished dinner but the place was very
very loud so there's never really a time
for me to ask so I didn't you know I
thought I was going to and we're only in
this houseboat for another like 12 hours
hopefully tomorrow morning I will ask
her I don't know we'll see this time it
has like flown by cuz we've had so much
fun I really enjoyed being here so it's
kind of sad that we're leaving tomorrow
so this is the third time Nikki and I
have lived together and what happens so
far every time is that sometime on the
second night she and I start talking
about like really real [ __ ] it's really
wonderful it was like the first time
that Garrett and I were really alone he
was telling me about this job that he
used to have he asked about the weddings
and we just like for a moment there felt
like old French catching up
[Music]
Wow of course is a gorgeous freakin
morning save the bacon noise good
morning good morning
I think at some point in my life I
actually could live here being on the
water itself is actually really really
fun I really enjoy it let's this part of
the country is gorgeous look at this
waking up to this every morning that's
unbelievable
hey Nick where do you wanna get brunch
next week yeah like on Saturday after
living on this houseboat with Garrett it
is definitely a place that has brought
us closer together we had enough time to
be in our own spaces in our own rooms
but also we did so many fun activities
together we went sailing we went
kayaking and we like had great space to
just sit and enjoy coffee together now
we're starting from like friends so it's
becoming like a better and better friend
actually takes like a lot of intimate
work and I'm excited to go to brunch or
maybe when we're both 80 will be
houseboat neighbors I hope it's right we
did it we're getting quick run
happy Saturday Niki
[Music]